La diagonalización cuántica de Krylov o KQD se refiere a resolver un problema de valores matriciales
proyectando la matriz en un subespacio preparado en una computadora cuántica, coherente con el método de Krylov, un
poderoso enfoque del álgebra lineal clásica. A lo largo de este video exploraremos para qué es útil el método de Krylov
y cómo y cuándo implementarlo en computadoras cuánticas.
Entonces, ¿qué es el método de Krylov? Supongamos que tenemos una matriz H relacionada con una actividad científica o empresarial, con n filas y n
columnas. Nos interesa el valor propio más bajo e 0 y el vector propio correspondiente psi 0. Definamos un
vector inicial v que podría estar motivado por la estructura de H o podría ser completamente aleatorio. El subespacio de Krylov
de orden r, que escribimos k r, se genera actuando con H sobre este
vector inicial r menos una vez, añadiendo el resultado de cada acción sucesiva de H
al conjunto de vectores generadores, es decir, kr es el espacio generado por los vectores v,
Hv, H al cuadrado v, y así sucesivamente. Estos vectores generalmente no serán ortogonales.
Clásicamente, solemos llevar a cabo un proceso de ortogonalización muy similar al procedimiento de Gram-Schmidt. Empiezas
normalizando el vector inicial V y llamas al resultado V 0. Luego, para el siguiente vector HV, le restas su
proyección sobre V 0 para hacer que los dos vectores sean ortogonales. Después normalizas el resultado. Continúas así,
actuando nuevamente con H y haciendo que el resultado sea ortogonal a todos los vectores añadidos anteriormente, hasta haber construido R
vectores ortonormalizados necesarios para generar tu subespacio de Krylov de dimensión R.
Una vez que tienes este subespacio, proyectas tu matriz sobre él y diagonalizas la matriz proyectada más pequeña. Hay
sutilezas y extensiones, pero ese es el método de Krylov en su nivel más simple.
Para tener una mejor idea de cómo funciona esto, veamos un ejemplo trivial. Si H es esta matriz y V se elige como este
vector, entonces empezaríamos normalizando V. Para generar el segundo vector en un subespacio de Krylov, actuamos
una vez con H sobre nuestro vector inicial y luego hacemos que ese resultado sea ortogonal a V 0.
Un poco de álgebra nos da esto para V1.
Esto no es útil para matrices tan pequeñas y normalmente no nos detendríamos en una dimensión de Krylov de dos. Pero si
proyectáramos H en nuestro nuevo espacio de Krylov K2, lo haríamos usando una matriz V
que tiene un vector de Krylov en cada columna y su traspuesta conjugada, que tiene vectores de Krylov en las filas. Entonces
obtendríamos esta matriz.
Esta matriz técnicamente tiene una dimensión menor que la original. Evidentemente, esta reducción no es útil a esta
escala. Este método está pensado para reducir matrices con miles o incluso millones de filas y columnas
a apenas unas pocas. Entonces, ¿por qué son útiles los métodos de Krylov? Resulta que esta sencilla prescripción
de acción del operador suele ser la forma más eficiente de aproximarse al estado de valor más bajo o estado fundamental de una matriz
operador. Hagamos esto un poco más explícito, aunque dejaremos la demostración completa para el texto adjunto. Queremos
resolver un problema de la forma H actuando sobre el vector x, lo que nos da una constante multiplicada por el vector x. Comencemos con una
estimación de nuestro vector propio x0. Esta es simplemente una solución aproximada. Tiene un error que llamamos e 0. Ahora queremos
hacer una actualización de esta estimación, que llamaremos x1, con la esperanza de mejorar nuestra aproximación. Podemos expresar esto como
el x0 original más alguna corrección p 0 que aún está por determinarse. Podemos
repetir este proceso de manera iterativa, añadiendo cada vez más vectores de corrección pi.
Evidentemente queremos que nuestro error se reduzca, pero no es solo el estado lo que nos importa. También nos importa la
acción de H sobre ese estado. Así que la cantidad que realmente queremos minimizar es la norma H de este error, o la norma de
la acción de H sobre este error.
Ahora podemos ver que esto es una expresión que involucra p 0 y podemos preguntarnos qué elecciones de p minimizan
esta norma H del error de manera más eficiente. ¿De qué espacio deberíamos seleccionar la corrección? Bajo ciertas
condiciones, como cuando H es simétrica y definida positiva, elegir las primeras r correcciones dentro de kr resulta
ser óptimo. En términos más simples, necesitamos alguna manera de preparar un buen subespacio sobre el que
podamos proyectar nuestro Hamiltoniano. Y en muchos casos, el subespacio de Krylov es el espacio generado por los vectores de las
correcciones más eficientes a nuestra estimación inicial.
Para una demostración real, consulta el texto que acompaña a este video.
Todo lo que hemos descrito hasta ahora puede hacerse de forma clásica. Entonces, ¿cómo y cuándo usaríamos una computadora cuántica?
Para matrices muy grandes, el método de Krylov puede requerir tiempos de cómputo prolongados y grandes cantidades de memoria. El tiempo
requerido para la operación matricial de H sobre V escala como N al cuadrado en el peor caso.
Y esto se hace para cada vector que queremos en nuestro subespacio. La dimensión del subespacio R generalmente no es una fracción significativa
de N y suele escalar como el logaritmo de N. Por lo tanto, generar todos los vectores escala
como del orden de N^2 log N.
Aunque hay otros pasos como la ortogonalización, este es el escalado dominante que hay que tener en cuenta.
La computación cuántica nos permite cambiar qué atributos del problema determinan el escalado del tiempo y los recursos
necesarios. En lugar de depender del tamaño de la matriz n en todos los aspectos, veremos cosas como el número de shots y
el número de términos de Pauli no conmutativos que componen un Hamiltoniano.
Exploremos cómo funciona esto.
Recuerda que el operador que evoluciona temporalmente un estado cuántico es el exponencial de iH sobre h barra. Y es
muy común, especialmente en computación cuántica, omitir la h barra de la notación.
Una forma de entender e incluso realizar tal función exponencial de un operador es observar su expansión
en serie de Fourier. Nota que esta operación actuando sobre algún vector inicial V produce una suma de términos
con potencias crecientes de H aplicadas al estado inicial. Parece que podemos construir nuestro subespacio de Krylov simplemente mediante la evolución temporal
de nuestro estado inicial estimado. Y eso es casi verdad. La advertencia está en
realizar la evolución temporal en una computadora cuántica real. Muchos de los términos del Hamiltoniano no conmutarán entre
sí. Entonces, aunque algunos operadores exponenciales simples como e a la menos i z corresponden a circuit simples,
los Hamiltonianos generales no, y dado que contienen términos no conmutativos,
no podemos simplemente descomponer el exponencial en un producto de exponenciales simples como sí podemos con los números. Por lo tanto,
esto no es trivial, pero es un proceso bien estudiado en computación cuántica. Llevamos a cabo la evolución temporal
en computadoras cuánticas usando un proceso llamado trotterización, que en sí mismo es un tema muy rico. Pero a un nivel muy alto,
al dividir la evolución temporal en pequeños pasos, digamos M pasos, limitamos los efectos de la no conmutatividad de
los términos. Llamemos al subespacio de Krylov de orden r que generamos en el contexto clásico usando potencias de h
directamente el subespacio de Krylov de potencias kpr.
Ahora generamos un espacio similar usando el operador de evolución temporal unitario u dado por el exponencial de iht.
A esto lo llamaremos el espacio de Krylov unitario kur.
El subespacio de Krylov de potencias kpr que usamos clásicamente no puede generarse directamente en una computadora cuántica, ya que h
no es un operador unitario. Se puede demostrar que usar el subespacio de Krylov unitario ofrece una convergencia similar
a la del subespacio de Krylov de potencias.
Específicamente, el error del estado fundamental converge de manera eficiente siempre que el estado inicial V tenga solapamiento con el
verdadero estado fundamental que no sea exponencialmente pequeño, y siempre que haya una brecha suficiente entre los estados
propios. Aquí, las potencias de u se convierten en diferentes pasos temporales. La k-ésima potencia de u avanza
un tiempo k * dt.
Podemos etiquetar el elemento del subespacio que evoluciona temporalmente un tiempo total kdt como s sub k. Podemos proyectar nuestro
Hamiltoniano H sobre el subespacio de Krylov unitario kur. En otras palabras,
calculamos cada elemento de la matriz de h en la base kur. A esto lo llamaremos
la matriz proyectada H tilde. Los elementos de la matriz H tilde están dados por estos valores esperados, que pueden ser
estimados usando la computadora cuántica.
Ten en cuenta que H puede escribirse como una suma de operadores de Pauli sobre diferentes qubits y que no todos los operadores de Pauli
pueden medirse simultáneamente. Podemos agrupar los términos de Pauli en grupos de términos que conmutan y medir todos
a la vez. Pero puede que necesitemos muchos de esos grupos para cubrir todos los términos. Así que el número de grupos conmutativos distintos en
los que se pueden distribuir los términos ngcp se vuelve importante. Si usamos un subespacio de Krylov unitario de dimensión r, la
matriz resultante tendrá dimensiones r * r. Si r es mucho menor que n, entonces hemos
avanzado de manera útil, y típicamente r es mucho menor que 100, lo que significa que podemos diagonalizarla fácilmente en una computadora
clásica. Pero recuerda que s n y s m no serán generalmente ortogonales. A veces
es posible diagonalizar una matriz en una base no ortogonal. Pero hay razones numéricas y físicas
para cambiar primero a una base ortogonal. Por eso resolvemos un problema generalizado de valores propios usando la matriz de Gram s.
El elemento mn de la matriz de Gram está dado por el producto interno de s m con s n.
Tanto los elementos de H tilde como los de S se calculan usando un test de Hadamard.
El problema generalizado de valores propios se convierte entonces en este.
Como se señaló anteriormente, la dimensión del subespacio de Krylov unitario R es exponencialmente menor que nuestra
dimensión de matriz inicial N. Así que este problema de valores es simple de resolver clásicamente.
Para resumir, comenzamos con un estado de referencia, luego lo evolucionamos durante diferentes períodos de tiempo para generar el
subespacio de Krylov unitario. Proyectamos nuestro Hamiltoniano sobre ese subespacio y también estimamos los solapamientos de los
vectores del subespacio. Finalmente, resolvemos el problema de valores generalizado de menor dimensión clásicamente. Comparemos qué
determina los costos computacionales de usar la técnica de Krylov clásicamente y cuánticamente. Ya esbozamos esto
para la versión clásica y no hay analogías perfectas entre los enfoques clásico y cuántico en todos los pasos. Pero esta tabla recoge algo del
escalado de los distintos pasos para consideración. Recuerda que los Hamiltonianos generalmente tienen términos que no pueden medirse simultáneamente porque no
conmutan. Agrupamos los términos del Hamiltoniano en grupos de operadores de Pauli que conmutan y que pueden medirse todos a la vez, y puede que necesitemos muchos
de esos grupos para dar cuenta de todos los términos que no conmutan. Construir H tilde en una computadora cuántica requiere
mediciones separadas para cada grupo de cadenas de Pauli que conmutan en el Hamiltoniano. Y cada una de ellas requiere muchas mediciones. Debemos hacer esto para R
al cuadrado diferentes elementos de la matriz, correspondientes a R al cuadrado combinaciones de distintos factores de evolución temporal. A veces
hay formas de reducir esto. Pero en este tratamiento aproximado, el tiempo requerido escala aproximadamente como
el número de mediciones por el número de grupos de términos de Pauli que conmutan * r^ 2.
Los elementos de s deben estimarse, lo que escala como el número de mediciones
al cubo. Vemos que la diagonalización cuántica de Krylov puede ser útil en casos donde el número de grupos de Pauli que conmutan
en el Hamiltoniano es relativamente pequeño.
Esta dependencia del escalado sugiere algunas aplicaciones donde el método de Krylov puede ser útil y otras donde probablemente
no lo será. Algunos Hamiltonianos tienen alta complejidad cuando se mapean a qubits, involucrando muchas cadenas de Pauli no conmutativas
que no pueden particionarse fácilmente en pocos grupos conmutativos.
Esto suele ser cierto en los problemas de química cuántica. Por ejemplo, esta complejidad presenta dos desafíos principales para las
computadoras cuánticas de corto plazo. Primero, la estimación de cada elemento de H tilde se vuelve costosa computacionalmente debido al
gran número de términos. Segundo, los circuits de trotterización requeridos se vuelven prohibitivamente profundos. Ambos puntos
serán menos problemáticos cuando las computadoras cuánticas alcancen la tolerancia a fallos, pero deben considerarse a corto plazo. Incluso los sistemas con mapeos más simples
que los de la química cuántica pueden experimentar los mismos impedimentos si los Hamiltonianos tienen demasiados términos no conmutativos.
El método de Krylov es más útil cuando el Hamiltoniano puede particionarse en relativamente pocos grupos de Pauli conmutativos
y cuando H es fácil de implementar en circuits de trotterización. Ambas condiciones se cumplen, por
ejemplo, para muchos modelos de red de interés en física. KQD es especialmente útil si se sabe muy poco sobre el
estado fundamental. Esto se debe a sus garantías de convergencia inherentes y a su aplicabilidad en escenarios donde
los métodos alternativos no son viables por un conocimiento insuficiente del estado fundamental.
Aunque KQD es una herramienta poderosa, los aspectos más lentos del protocolo, en particular la estimación de cada
elemento del Hamiltoniano proyectado y el solapamiento de los estados de Krylov, representan oportunidades de mejora. Un
enfoque alternativo consiste en aproximar el estado de Krylov usando circuits de trotterización y luego muestrear el
estado aproximado para obtener una proyección sobre la base computacional, y después proyectar h sobre el subespacio
generado por estos estados de la base computacional.
En los casos en que es aplicable, esta metodología conocida como diagonalización cuántica de Krylov basada en muestreo, SKQD,
ofrece potencialmente reducciones significativas en tiempo y recursos en comparación con el KQD tradicional.
La integración de las técnicas de subespacio de Krylov con los métodos de muestreo en SKQD representa una frontera apasionante en
los algoritmos cuánticos.